estamos en comunicación con el diputado
saliente de la circunscripción de la
vall de ágape de candidato para la
elección provincial del primero de
octubre por el partido liberal de québec
saúl polo bienvenido como está saúl
muchísimas gracias paloma saludos a
todos los oyentes de radio canal
internacional en español saúl los
liberales de que ve que están pidiendo
otro mandato después de 15 años con una
breve interrupción de 18 meses pero 15
años de estar en el poder están pidiendo
en un nuevo mandato a los quebequenses
cual sería un según usted el val el
balance que se puede hacer de estos 15
años en términos o lo positivo de lo que
han logrado en los liberales hasta el
momento pues primero que todo paloma es
cierto que es el mismo partido pero no
es el mismo equipo y el equipo en los
últimos 15 años se renovó muchísima
mente y aún más con esta elección
yo creo que los colegas que participaron
en la elección de 2003 con el ex primer
ministro sangre
yo creo que quedan menos de 5 sobre un
total de candidatos de 125 candidatos y
candidatas entonces es cierto que es el
mismo partido pero es un contexto muy
diferente un equipo muy diferente el
balance que yo hago y específicamente
los últimos 4 años porque es el gobierno
en el cual yo participe colabore en el
cual me implique es un balance positivo
sobre todo a nivel económica estamos
hablando de una economía que ve quién se
actualmente que vive una cierta envidia
de parte de los vecinos de ontario y de
las otras provincias de canadá tenemos
una tasa de crecimiento económico de
superior a 3.5 por ciento cuatro
presupuestos gubernamentales
equilibrados algo
jamás hecho en los últimos 60 años
tenemos una tasa de desempleo que se
sitúa alrededor de 5% incluso en ciertas
regiones estaba mirando que la voz en
una de las regiones vecinas a los eeuu
al sur de la región de quebec la tasa de
desempleo es de 2.5 por ciento entonces
los desafíos que estamos viviendo
actualmente tienen que ver
principalmente con el tema de laboral
y no tanto es todo lo opuesto del de una
taza es importante es todo lo contrario
es una escasez de trabajadores
calificados y no calificados en toda la
provincia de khyber y digamos que es el
tema principal a partir del cual hay
otras hay otros debates que se han
organizado que sea entonces digamos que
es un balance bien positivo ahora
en abril del 2018 hubo un sondeo en toda
la provincia y entre las principales
entre comillas de excepciones de la
población quebequense con respecto al
régimen liberal era el sistema de salud
estaban decepcionados con respecto a la
la agilidad a la particularidad a las
particularidades del sistema de salud
quebequense que propone en esta en esta
ocasión para que cambie y para que la
percepción negativa que los quebequenses
pueden tener el sistema de salud pueda
cambiar en los próximos cuatro años
habiendo ya estado en el poder estos
últimos 15 claro yo entiendo
perfectamente
esa cierta decepción porque no tenemos
que olvidar que el sistema de salud a
nivel de presupuesto en la provincia de
québec representa 50 por ciento entonces
estamos hablando de un ministerio y
sobre todo un sistema de salud enorme
pesado y cuando se habla de agilidad
pues tenemos que poner las cosas en
perspectiva sin embargo después de
cuatro años de reformas estamos
empezando a ver resultados muy positivos
y creemos que con el tiempo vamos a ver
resultados aún más positivos sobre todo
por ejemplo cuando analizamos el tema de
los doctores de familia porque la
accesibilidad de los doctores de familia
es un tema recurrente en los últimos
15-20 años la dificultad hace más de 10
años el gobierno decidió por ejemplo
permitir nuevas facultades de medicina
en la universidad de sherbrooke y
universidad dentro aliviar para
incrementar el número de médicos
formados en la provincia de québec algo
que había sido limitado en las en las
décadas anteriores
al año 2007-2008 más o menos hoy estamos
hablando que en los últimos cuatro años
hay más de 1.200.000 quebequenses que
tienen acceso un médico de familia más
de lo que
de los que ya tenían acceso médico de
familia antes de la elección de 2014
estamos hablando por ejemplo para aquí
para una región como la región de la
vall con una población de casi 440 mil
ciudadanos de un porcentaje de
accesibilidad médico de familia que
estaba inferior a los 70 por ciento en
el año 2014 a un porcentaje superior al
81 por ciento hoy día
reconozco que no todo es perfecto
todavía hay mucho trabajo por hacer por
eso es que estamos presentándonos para
pedir otro mandato a la población para
seguir estas reformas
y seguir trabajando en la primera línea
de accesibilidad del sistema de salud y
sobre todo también adecuar los servicios
que se le ofrecen a las personas de edad
que sea a domicilio o que sean las
residencias gubernamentales también
ahora ha habido algunas críticas también
en cuanto a la manera en que se ha
acomodado digamos el dinero según los
sectores según los el sector de la salud
es el sector de la educación incluso hoy
en la mañana leíamos una carta publicada
en el diario le devoir de los de los
empresarios que quieren que sea que se
inviertan más en las empresas locales y
menos en las empresas internacionales y
que se reparte ese dinero de alguna de
otra manera no necesariamente solo en
las empresas sino también las
universidades en la educación y es una
de las cosas que preocupan mucho a los
quebequenses también ha habido tantos
casos de escuelas mal mal mantenidas
como al mantenimiento con champiñones
con cosas que han tenido que cambiar a
los niños de escuela entonces qué es lo
que se propone qué es lo que propondría
un gobierno liberal
para los próximos meses para digamos
aliviar estas preocupaciones en términos
de la educación como tal y la
infraestructura en el medio educativa
bueno en los últimos dos años se hizo
una reinversión importante a nivel de
educación a nivel no sólo a nivel de
infraestructura sino también a nivel de
personal y sobre todo personal
especializado si por ejemplo miro joan
mir en la circunscripción que represento
en los últimos cuatro años se hicieron
más de casi 30 millones de inversiones
en tren en renovaciones de las
infraestructuras actuales se invirtió
más de 15 millones en remodelar una y
una
una escuela de adultos para convertirlo
en una escuela para primaria en aquí en
la región de la vall se está viviendo un
final menudo muy diferente en los
últimos dos años he intentado a la
reinversión masiva que se ha hecho la
comisión escolar aquí la principal
dificultad que tienen o las dos
principales dificultad que tiene es que
tiene tienen los presupuestos para
construir nuevas escuelas pero hay una
escasez de terrenos donde se pueden
construir las nuevas escuelas entonces
ese es un dilema es un trabajo que se
tiene que hacer con la alcaldía de la
vall y el otro desafío que tienen es
reclutar personal especializado
tienen el objetivo desde hace 18 meses
de recortar 150 profesionales
especializados para ayudar a los
profesores y sobre todo ofrecer el
servicio a los niños en las escuelas
primarias y secundarias han han logrado
reclutar 50 profesionales especializados
tienen el presupuesto para reclutar más
de 100 pero la dificultad es que las
diferentes condiciones escolares se
están peleando para reclutar cada uno de
estos profesionales
en el área de educación entonces el
presupuesto y el dinero está disponible
la dificultad ahora es cómo realizar
estos proyectos de nuevas escuelas del
dinero está el dinero está por ejemplo
no solo a nivel de escuelas primarias y
secundarias también por ejemplo en mi
circunscripción tengo el colegio de
monjas y que es una institución de nivel
pre universitario
y la dificultad que ellos tienen es
justamente tener acceso a
y terrenos para poder incrementar la
capacidad de el celler para recibir
mayor número de estudiantes entonces son
desafíos y proyectos los cuales estamos
trabajando pero justamente los esfuerzos
que se hicieron al principio de nuestro
gobierno hoy permitieron no sólo de
equilibrar los presupuestos pero tan
pero también de generar excedentes que
nos permiten invertir esos excedentes
presupuestales en educación salud y
sobre todo las familias también todo eso
está ahí todo esto está relacionado
principalmente a la buena salud de la
economía si no fuera por el incremento
de 3.5 por ciento de la economía
quebequense no no tuviéramos ese
excedente de recursos financieros no
puedo dejarlo ir saúl polo sin
preguntarle a él el tema de la
inmigración ha sido un tema que ha sido
muy debatido en justamente los debates
pero también en los discursos que han
dado los diferentes líderes de partido y
que esto estarían eventualmente lo
algunos de ellos
el primer ministro de la provincia
esta mañana la alcaldesa de montreal
dijo algo que me llamó la atención
porque fue la primera en decirlo dijo
los los inmigrantes no son mercancía
están ahí para sí para paliar un poco la
escasez de mano de obra pero están
también para formar parte de un proyecto
un proyecto colectivo un proyecto de
nación un proyecto de sociedad entonces
yo quisiera preguntarle para ustedes
para el partido liberal cómo sería ese
proyecto de sociedad quebequense en la
que se incluiría a los inmigrantes
pues nuestra visión de un proyecto de
sociedad que se incluye la inmigración
es justamente nosotros
consideramos de que el trabajo es
valorar
cada cada persona el trabajo es le
aporta a cada persona una una capacidad
de sentirse bien integrado también
entonces por eso nosotros nos hemos
enfocado en hablar positivamente el
aporte de la inmigración y sobre todo
que la prioridad a nivel del inmigración
no es hablar de temas religiosos o de
temas de idioma como tal pero es hablar
también del aporte que ellos pueden
aportar a ayudar sobre ese desafío de
del crecimiento económico por una parte
pero también de explicar que si queremos
hablar de buena integración en la
sociedad quebequense tenemos que ofrecer
estas oportunidades laborales para que
los inmigrantes los nuevos quebequenses
puedan sentir que ellos no sólo aportan
sino que también que la economía y la
sociedad que ve que se les da con qué
soñar y construir un futuro eso es que
todo yo personalmente me mantenía
alejado a los temas de esos debates
porque me parece que llevamos ya
demasiados años hablando de la
porte o no o de la discriminación o el
racismo reconozco que han sido debates
que han generado mucha división
personalmente yo me he tratado y tratado
esforzarme de hablar de lo positivo y
sobretodo de enfocarme en real en la en
las necesidades de las personas
inmigrantes entonces
yo estoy terminando un mandato en el
cual uno de mis desafíos fue de darle el
mayor reconocimiento por ejemplo a
nuestra comunidad hispana y
latinoamericana dentro del gobierno de
quebec y uno de los
logros de los padres me siento orgulloso
fue por ejemplo de ayudar a la opción de
un proyecto de ley que reconoce el mes
de octubre como el mes de la herencia
hispana
aquí en quebec y eso es un aporte eso es
un récord es un digamos es un
reconocimiento y es sobre todo es un
logro positivo que muestra que podemos
dejar de lado todos esos debates que a
veces muy negativos y mirar en lo
positivo y ese es un logro positivo del
cual yo me siento muy orgullo y
orgulloso saúl fue lo diputado saliente
de la circunscripción de la vall de
rapid y candidato para esa misma
circunscripción en la elección
provincial del primero de octubre por el
partido liberal
muchas gracias por conversar con
nosotros hoy muchas gracias para una y
mis agradecimientos a radio canadá
internacional en español hasta luego
hasta luego